okay so we're continuing our tour
through the delusions of FoxNews today I
have two foxnews religious clips and one
is an example of a religious leader
being responsible about coronavirus
that's the first one the second foxnews
coronavirus religious clip is a
religious not being completely
irresponsible about coronavirus okay so
let's start remember that Donald Trump
at one point wanted the country opened
by Easter and it's a sort of god complex
gone wrong I've talked about this before
Trump seeing himself as a sort of Jesus
like figure resurrecting the country on
Eastern Easter much like the biblical
Easter story of Jesus's resurrection now
ultimately it didn't work would be
hugely dangerous to reopen the country
this Sunday that's when Easter is
imagined we're not even at the peak yet
Trump was thinking about reopening but
there's a lot of really big evangelical
churches that don't care they keep
gathering huge crowds and Fox News host
Laura Ingraham really wants religious
gatherings to continue because otherwise
as she says nobody will gather to pray
until out Anthony foul she says it's
okay which to me makes sense right I
mean like don't we need doctors and not
pastors deciding when it's safe to
gather in huge groups so check out Laura
Ingraham on her show truly vile while
interviewing a Catholic priest father
Marie and then some other guy I don't
know who the other guy is but he doesn't
speak during this segment check it out
yeah I think father Marie a lot of
people especially the working-class
people of our country the people who pay
the bills who don't get a lot of
accolades people that you know a lot of
us came from they're the one this is
like the time where they need a public
affirmation of their faith it's it's all
well and good to say stay at home I
heard under some priests on TV might
have even been on our network saying oh
it's the domestic church you know yeah I
get that but it's this is this is Holy
Week and and just to say because the
bishops say you can't I don't know I've
got to say out blessing the palms public
you know blessings of people far apart
otherwise you know maybe we won't have
mass until Anthony
she says it's okay after Christmas or
something I mean I guess what the
bishops be okay with that I don't know
the people who work they need to go to
church and laura ingraham seems
incredulous that wait people are staying
home during Holy Week how is this
possible
so there's Laura Ingraham being insane
but now we get to father Murray's
response father Murray's response is
absolutely correct
now there's two funny little things that
you'll notice and father Murray's
response one is that he refers to
coronavirus as Korah known a virus which
I just love it's extraordinarily
endearing and as he does it his head
phone also falls out of his right ear so
a lot of things visually going wrong for
father Murray but he is absolutely right
and doing the responsible thing and for
that he should be commended take a look
and they put out you know that disease
into their congregation and so many
people have died in Italy and you know
we don't want to repeat that here you
have to get ahead of the curve you can't
just keep things you know as as they
were and it's regretful but you know
whatever you do the least of my bread
and you do to me if you sacrifice going
to mass so that people don't get sick I
think that's a form of praising God so
the Catholic priest pointing out
essentially stay the hell home actually
saying the responsible thing you should
stay home priests have died in Italy
this is not good staying home to avoid
being sick is good God's not going to be
bad God's not going to punish you so
good for father Murray here he's doing
absolutely the the correct thing and
unfortunately on Fox News we continue to
see every dangerous narrative that is
being parodied by Trump and people
around him
repeated ad nauseam chloroquine
chloroquine chloroquine what do you have
to lose take it take it take it we got
to go to church prayer is so important
keep
thing keep donating to your church so
good for father Marie here for getting
involved in saying no that's the wrong
thing a responsible example of a
religious leader commenting on what has
to be done about coronavirus
unfortunately now we get to the
irresponsible one what if you could read
ten books in just one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do it's called blinka Stan what
they do is take thousands of popular
nonfiction books they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes blinka snakes sure that
you're getting all of the important core
insights from each book so it's perfect
for exploring a book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for there's a full
book you're thinking about buying you
can use blankets to get a sample first
just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink kiss
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video